well joining me now is the shadow
foreign secretary david lammy mr lammy
good morning to you and thank you so
much for talking to us um let's start
with what joe biden said last night what
do you make of what he said
well across
nato we have the strongest intelligence
capability
in the world and it's clear that
troops are in a forward
uh posture a forward maneuver
they've increased substantially since
the hundred thousand troops
that we were talking about just a few
um weeks ago and all of the intelligence
says
that they are very close to being able
to act so the international community
has to main resolved united and firm
that this could happen
and that
any consequences
of invasion will be met
uh with great severity in terms of
sanctions
and just sanctions do you think
well it's absolutely clear that there
will not be boots on the ground but of
course we support
uh ukraine in its
quest for its own sovereignty and its
own territorial
integrity
and so it means that as
leaders gather in munich
uh to confer they're absolutely clear
that we will have to
hurt very hard the plutocrats that
support putin
cut them out of the
finance of the international community
make it impossible for them to get their
hands on the semiconductors that support
their military equipment
and ensure that we apply pressure on
russian banks as well that is the sort
of severe consequence that will follow
and do you think that would actually be
enough though
well clearly uh it would cause great
damage to the russian economy uh and
uh we hope
that those around putin
uh will
get him to pause
because clearly we're talking about a
country where there are a lot of people
who make a lot of money too much money
in cities like london and that's why
labour's been raising real issues about
implementing the russia report and
around the dirty money
that effectively uses london as a
laundromat for all of those reasons we
should remember
that
it's going after the cash that applies
the pressure that might
bring this to an end
because there is the argument um that
it's gone beyond that now and it's gone
beyond putin just having to keep those
oligarchs happy
and he he doesn't really need them
anymore
no one knows what's in putin's mind uh
he's now been in power for over 20 years
um and clearly ultimately this is a
decision for him and there is concern
that if you like that he's an echo
chamber uh unable to hear calmer voices
uh uh that do exist uh in the kremlin uh
but nevertheless
um
in the end that west has to act with
force
but yes we know that we cannot commit uh
troops on the ground in ukraine
i i don't know if you heard what debauch
elwood has been saying um to us here at
sky news a couple of days ago he was
saying that nato blinked we should have
had boots on the ground before we got to
this point
i mean my own assessment is that nato
isn't
that sorry that ukraine
is not within the nato family that we
have to be clear about what it means to
be in nato and in the end uh nato is not
an aggressive uh force it is a defensive
force that's the first thing and i think
it'd be wrong uh to break with that the
second thing is when i was in kiev
uh talking right across society no one
was saying at that time
look please commit troops what they were
saying
is thank you for the training that
you've given our military uh
there's more uh equipment that we need
to deal with putin in the event
of an incursion or an invasion and of
course
western community and nato
allies are supporting ukraine in that
endeavor and have actually been for now
for some several years
given the fact that we've seen these
nuclear drills brought forward to today
military drills taking place in belarus
and the fact that as you said we are
seeing more troops coming to the border
helicopters
field hospitals what do you make of
boris johnson going to the munich
conference today and saying
diplomacy can still prevail do you think
that's true
well look of course it we must
fight for diplomacy
right up to
the last moment so of course we hope
that it can prevail uh but look let's be
clear um
belarus and leschenko uh very close to
vladimir putin
uh the area of translation in moldova
also uh
under his auspices that's why we've also
had to withdraw
um our
own um
or instruct our nationals to leave those
countries to be cautious and uh embassy
staff as well
and for all of those reasons it's that
encirclement if you like
of ukraine
and certainly that ability
to move towards kiev that makes the
international community
very very cautious of anything that's
coming out
of russia and
and very aware
that military action could follow in the
coming hours and days
okay mr lammie thank you so much for
talking to us mr lambie is the shadow
foreign secretary
thank you